ils sont sur la piste d'un travail ou à
la recherche du bon profil demandeurs
d'emploi et recruteurs se sont retrouvés
pour le sky emploi jeudi 4 avril au
vélodrome national au milieu de la piste
cinq mille offres d'emploi à pourvoir
là clairement non on a dvd profil de
poste qu'on va pouvoir recruter dans
l'immédiat alors que nos annonces on
n'avait pas forcément de candidats qui
postulent et sur ses annonces là j'ai eu
à choisir parmi 50 candidats donc
cinquante candidats quand vous êtes une
société de 12 personnes
c'est quelque chose de très précieux
nous sommes dans un grand bassin où il
ya énormément d'entreprises donc je
pense que s'il leur rendez-vous qu'il
fallait absolument pas rater
quelles compétences vous mettez en avant
dans vos entretiens bas que j'ai
travaillé pendant cinq ans en suisse
dans des assurances dans des oeuvres
auront au total 160 entreprises ont
participé à cette deuxième édition tous
les secteurs économiques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines représenter
3000 visiteurs et 2500 entretien à la
clé la qualité des visiteurs à la
qualité des
des cv moi j'ai fait le tour entre 14h
et 18h je peux vous dire que j'ai eu
beaucoup beaucoup de contrats faute
pré-contrat signé cette journée
l'occasion aussi de lancer la plateforme
sky emploi un nouvel outil pour
assembler les offres d'emploi sur les
douze communes de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est vraiment la valeur ajoutée de
cette plate forme c'est la notion de
matching c'est à dire en fonction de
comment je peux avoir rentré mon profil
on va me proposer les offres le plus
adéquat à mon profil de leur côté des
entreprises créé leur profil et mettent
en ligne leurs offres pour vous inscrire
rendez vous sur le site sky emploi.fr